president Trump welcomed the president
of Nigeria to the White House yeah the
the meeting started awkwardly when Trump
said come on in Kanye pornstars stormy
Daniels is suing president Trump for
defamation for something he said in a
tweet yeah yeah yeah when they heard
this Muslims african-americans gays and
Hillary Clinton said you can do that I
like this interesting the tree planted
on the White House lawn remember the
tree planted on the White House lawn by
President Trump and French president
Mike Rowan has been removed and taken
away yes after hearing about it Melania
disguised herself as a tree
so stupid I'm sure a lot of you saw The
Avengers movie this weekend that this
weekend Avengers infinity war pulled in
640 million dollars and 40 million
dollars yeah that works out to a million
dollars for each superhero in the movie
now the joke there is there's a lot of
superheroes in the movie still not worth
it huh
how's that burn doing that's how bad
that joke was i'm reinvestigating i'm
reinvestigating your wound so were you
trying it j-just keep it moist that's
important Pinterest Pinterest Pinterest
has a new feature that makes it more
accessible to blind people I think it's
very k yeah and not to be outdone tinder
is adding a voice that tells blind
people this person is fatter in real
life
keep moving keep moving
you